I just had the weirdest dream last night  that our business crater that wasn't a  dream and the meteor was wrecking ball  named plans which is why I'm rebranding  spore text and we're gonna pivot back to  football  [Music]  the organization hasn't forgotten about  you how much to give my life in that  field who's sacrificing for me besides  my mom what are you sacrificing  I want to get paid these guys have  authenticity  everything we do is straight-up nasty  make Bank and keep it real Uncle Fester  came to play today okay the greatest  athlete on the planet is gonna shock the  world the kid stays and if not by coming  to you  and everything you've got your dirty  little hands in  the old system is a scam  yes don't tell me that you decided to  take on one of the most corrupt and  powerful organizations in all of sports  I did  you